la banque du canada a acheté pour plus
de 180 milliards de dollars
d'obligations du gouvernement canadien
depuis mars 2020 la banque se défend de
financer le gouvernement trudeau et ses
programmes de soutien aux entreprises et
aux citoyens
on en parle ce soir avec jean boivin
directeur du blackrock investment
institute ancien sous-gouverneur à la
banque du canada
bonsoir monsieur boivin bonsoir monsieur
fillion dire que la boxe finances le
gouvernement
est-ce que c'est exagéré de dire cela
c'est exagéré c'est pas la bonne façon
de caractériser ce qui se passe la
banque du canada est en mode
d'assouplissement pour répondre à la
situation actuelle s'avère que les deux
des douze ticona budgétaires et
monétaires travaille dans la même
direction mais c'est pas vraiment
différent de ce qui se passe en temps
normal lorsque la banque qui abaisse ses
taux
ça crée une marge de manoeuvre fiscale
plus grande parce que les coûts de la
dette deviennent moins élevé c'est pas
différente ce qui se passe maintenant
mais c'est clair que ça devient dents et
on est dans un monde de ski mont
quantitatif ça devient plus plus visible
ou ça donne cette impression là mais
c'est pas un c'est pas un financement
mais les bons du trésor les obligations
qui sont émis par le gouvernement
canadien
c'est en grande partie la banque du
canada qui les achètent en ce moment oui
mais de comme l'ont fait plusieurs
boucles banque centrale en fait ce qui
est intéressant c'est que là au canada
c'est la première fois dans ce
territoire alors que plusieurs autres
pays ont dû le faire après 2008 et
c'était ce qu'on appelait les palais les
politiques monétaires non
conventionnelles pour essayer de
stimuler l'économie
une fois qu'on est rendu au niveau
inférieur des taux lorsque la banque
populaire se sont tous il faut réessayer
baisser les taux à plus long terme et
donc ça s'apprend des instruments qui
vont directement affectées c'est à plus
long terme et c'est dans le même cadre
et la même optique que les baisses de
taux habituel le gouvernement du canada
pourrait-il x 20 par 30 par 40 son
déficit comme il le fait présentement
sans avoir le concours d'une banque
centrale de la banque du canada qui
rachète les obligations oui oui en fait
présentement l'aller
s'avère que les deux outils vont dans la
même direction que je comme je le disais
mais le côté budgétaire il irait de
l'avant d'autres où c'est nécessaire
donc est ce qui va être intéressant pour
l'instant c'est impossible de critiquer
ou de houe de voir une coordination
inadéquate la question va se poser plus
lorsque la situation va évoluer d'une
façon que les deux outils devons
travailler en opposé lorsque si on a des
signes d'inflation
un revirement d'un petit moteur une
recette un certain resserrement à ce
moment là sont des doutes sur
l'efficacité où l'habilité le monde
centrale à s'ajuster
le seul côté là ça devrait aussi dans ce
moment là qu'on pourrait se poser ces
questions de coordination inapproprié
mais à ce stade si on est dans un monde
où il ya peu de doute sur la nécessité
que les deux instruments donc
officiellement la banque du canada fait
quoi exactement
en ce moment oui elle est officiellement
forfait prendre le manuel d'instruction
qui a été déployée dans le monde depuis
c'est même un peu avant son tendre au
japon qui est de north qu'une fois qu'on
est on atteint le niveau inférieur le
fait que les taux directeurs peut pas
aller plus bas 0 pour arriver à stimuler
l'économie au delà de dix ans en période
de pandémie
on a envie d'utiliser des outils
nationale font partie de la boîte à
outils que la banque du canada déjà vais
déjà me annoncée de la voir quand
j'étais là en 2009 2010 si on avait on
avait établi qu ici on avait le besoin
et on irait avec des outils additionnels
qui sont l'achat d'actifs
gouvernementales dans le but de baisser
des toits plus long terme donc danser le
taux à court terme et est contraint on
peut aussi les fluence et les taux à
plus long terme pour faire la même chose
qui est traditionnel qui est de stimuler
l'économie à travers une baisse de taux
mais qui te baise fois plus long terme
est ce que le gouvernement du canada
devra racheter les obligations qu'ils
ont été achetés par la banque du canada
rendue à terme
donc une fois que vous enverrez comme
l'a mentionné va gérer son bilan et
caisses comment les choses vont évoluer
mais il va arriver un moment donné où la
bande se poser la question est ce qu est
ce qu on réduit notre rythme d'achat
d'accord avant de vendre il faut d'abord
réduire le rythme des achats mensuels ou
hebdomadaires dont l'impressionnante
épargne en anglais une fois qu'on a le
tpr y faire la question pourrait se
poser est ce que vous pensez qu'on
réduit la taille du bilan et à ce moment
là c'est pas nécessairement que le
gouvernement doit directement leur
acheter mais il faudrait que ce soit
financée par d'autres entités ça peut
être rendre sur les marchés ils
s'appellent les actions financières ça
peut être des individus qui achètent et
obligations là mais il veut vraiment que
ça soit absorbée par le système hôte que
la bande canada donc vous et moi des
investisseurs
locaux canadiens ou étrangers qui
rachèterait donc ses obligations
éventuellement ce qui peut faire monter
quand même le coût d'intérêt et il le
coût de la dette le coût de la dette du
gouvernement du canada à ce moment là
effectivement donc tout ce qu'ils
peuvent l'acheter je travaille position
financière qui gère des fonds fédéraux
question d'actifs et on alloue des
obligations gouvernementales
cette façon de générer des rendements
pour protéger les portefeuilles pour les
clients donc ça peut être dans l'exemple
et à ce moment là effectivement dans la
même dans la même idée que l'achat des
obligations à ce stade ci admet amedi à
des taux bas ou peut-être même à
l'épaisse plus long terme sont sans voix
en marche arrière ou se renverse la
vente
ça va faire à la pression contraire sur
les taux et donc ça va amener une touche
de tout contenu mimos duos de tous à la
mesure qui ne concerne cette direction
là un mot sur le dollar canadien qui
semble inquiéter la banque du canada en
ce moment le larqué nazis étaient au
canada étant donné qu'on est économie
qui dépend beaucoup sur le commerce
international
l'odeur qu'elle a dit joue un rôle
important dans la transmission de la
politique monétaire et donc dans un
contexte il ya d'autres facteurs qui
peuvent amener une hausse du dollar
canadien c'est certain que ça va être un
vent contraire qui va à l'encontre de ce
qu'on essaie de faire en termes de
politiques budgétaires et fiscales
budgétaires et monétaires pardon et donc
à ce moment là c'est une considération
que la banque du canada doit prendre en
compte évidemment est tout autre chose
de tonte égales par ailleurs ça fait en
sorte que si le dollar est trop fort
plus fort ça va amener peut-être les
amener à assouplir davantage ou à
maintenir les programmes en place jean
boivin merci pour cette analyse ce soir
merci beaucoup pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit